pour classer tous les mégots qu'on a
ramassé c'est pas franchement dans la
vue de la bien de 3000 postes quoi tout
ça ça représente beaucoup de
suremballage large existe des
alternatives à ces simples pour pouvoir
s'en passer à ses récits on a réduit sur
les sur la poubelle jaune tout ce qui
est recyclable de soixante dix ans
notamment parce qu'on vient faire nos
courses en vrac jeter quelque chose à la
poubelle ce n'est pas anodin ça a des
conséquences à poubelles c'est pas un
trou noir dans laquelle les choses
disparaissent salut c'est avec celle de
tout le monde s'en fout et aujourd'hui
on va vous parler des déchets de ce
qu'il faudrait faire
et surtout de ce qu'il faut arrêter de
faire parce qu'il ya plein de trucs
qu'il faut arrêter de faire voilà ce qui
s'appelle une équipe qui est fait c'est
un ramassage de déchets avec des
citoyens
et puis on ramasse tous les déchets
qu'on trouve sur notre chemin là on le
fait dans notre ville mais on peut le
faire dans nos forêts dans nos plages
etc
l'idée est à la fois de nettoyer
concrètement dans notre ville mais aussi
de prendre conscience de l'impact de
notre consommation et de la pollution de
nos emballages et la pollution sont ce
large du terme
c'est important de le faire en ville
parce qu'en ville tu te rends compte que
le peu de zones naturelles qu'on a en
ville c'est les endroits les plus
pollués
ces genres comme si c'était la poubelle
quoi faut te rends compte que jeter un
papier par terre bon déjà c'est ça c'est
débile mais jeter un papier où jeter
quelque chose à la poubelle c'est pas
anodin ça a des conséquences la poubelle
c'est pas un trou noir dans laquelle des
choses disparaissent c'est pas parce
qu'une fois qu'on jette on en est plus
responsable le des chiens dans les
responsables jusqu'à ce qu'ils
disparaissent et un déchet alors général
du plastique sade mais milan a dû
paraître c'est un mec s'est dit je
pollue je fais ça joli un peu artistique
ça va faire un moment qui hélas gobelets
en plus lassé que voilà des sodas des
bouteilles en plastique etc
les bouteilles en plastique arrêtons
cette bouteille en plastique va mettre
entre 100 et 1000 ans selon le plastique
à se détériorer dans la nature
[Musique]
c'est une matière qui va être recyclés
plusieurs fois trois quatre fois grand
maximum évidemment comme c'est fait à
base de pétrole et d'autres produits
chimiques
ça va évidemment polluer son
environnement là juste là c'est un enfer
où il y est belle à tout y est c'est
beaucoup trop petit normalement ça c'est
du plastique donc ça peut dans l'idée se
recycler mais comme c'est trop petit ça
passe à travers les machines de tri est
donc un direct mais alors cache quoi
sans attendre sa fille nine ans à 80 %
de déchets qui se trouve dans l'océan
ils viennent de nos rues ils viennent de
la terre l'océan on lui doit une
respiration sur deux aujourd'hui nos
océans et sont en train d'étouffer
debarnot de pollution de partout le
dérèglement climatique en ailier
[Musique]
et on pense toujours que ça vient
d'ailleurs
mais au niveau européen même au niveau
français la mer méditerranée est une des
mers les plus polluées et c'est de notre
responsabilité à les y aller si pardon
excusez noah étoiles à planètes
et quel moment tu te dise voilà tu vois
ça c'est à dire un truc qui est quand
même de manière de manière assez
naturelle naturelle quoi tu dis c'est un
beau son bar alors ça c'est tonique 500
litres d'eau au m c'est quand même
terrible ça c'est du plastique ça ah
ouais mais ça y est il ya une partie de
plastique là dedans mixer avec plein
d'autres trucs parfaitement dégueulasse
le mégot de cigarette comme on l'a dit
déjà pollue 500 litres d'eau à lui tout
seul là dedans il ya des milliers de
substances chimiques faut savoir qu'il
ya du plastique là dedans au site
le film qui est là dedans c'est du
plastique on en rêve 40 milliards par an
en france savait pas quoi faire de votre
dimanche
et bien venir ramasser des mégots avec
vous de passer une dimanche en famille
là c'est quand même mieux c'est quand
même plus sympa
[Musique]
photo de voir des gens comme ça qui se
motive et de marquer des gens qui sont
là et qui est
et qui sont prêts à se bouger avec le
sourire mais tout s est bien sûr que
c'est
c'est rassurant pour la suite et pour
classer tous les mégots qu'on a ramassé
je sais pas franchement dhr à vue d'oeil
l'a bien de 3000 facile pas de mégots on
a fait une avenue là on a fait une
avenue dans une ville de 1 pays voilà
non mais si on a toutes les bouteilles
ski et bouteilles en plastique
là on a tous ce qu'est les papiers en
atrous qui allait les pailles les petits
plastique les paquets de cigarettes
on est contents d'en nettoyer notre
ville en fait on a on a fait une bonne
action et on l'a pas fait en plus juste
pour se déculpabiliser où se racheter
une conscience on l'a fait parce qu'on
avait envie de le faire ça nous semblait
important c'est pas contre les déchets
c'est juste pour que ce soit propre
c'est super concluons là-dessus
marseillais moi je trouve ça génial et
très bien j'adore ce qu'ils disent ce
garçon
salut jumelles président de la maison de
zéro déchet venez je vais vous faire
visiter
venez avec moi on va faire ensemble une
autopsie de poubelles en moyenne ce sont
570 kg qui sont jetés par an et par
habitant en france seulement 35 à 40%
100 recyclé ici on a une poubelle type
on va voir ensemble justement de quoi
elle est composée et comment on peut
éviter tous ces déchets est ce qu'on
voit c'est que dans cette poubelle la
majorité des déchets est composé de
plastique
cette bouteille plastique par exemple si
on a la chance qu'elle soit jetée dans
la bonne ben elle va effectivement être
recyclés mais le plastique n'est pas
recyclable à l'infini
contrairement aux verts il va falloir
toujours rajouter de la matière pour
pouvoir produire du nouveau plastique
dans cette poubelle on a beaucoup de
contenants pour le jambon pour les
biscuits pour les pâtes
on a aussi beaucoup de sacs plastiques
tout ça ça représente beaucoup de
suremballage alors qu'il existe des
alternatives à ces simples pour éviter
de produire tous ces déchets à la maison
du zéro déchet on vous en propose un
certain nombre je vais vous les montrer
par exemple pour les bouteilles
plastiques on a les traditionnels gourde
dont il faut se serait emparé le
cellophane et l'aluminium ce sont aussi
des choses qu'on retrouve beaucoup dans
nos poubelles malheureusement et qui ne
sont pas très bonnes pour
l'environnement
l'alternative ce sont ces emballages
réutilisables à la cire d'abeille que
vous pouvez mettre sur vos contenants ou
emballés ressemble which avec et il
suffit juste de les laver avec de l'eau
froide dans la salle de bain on trouve
aussi pas mal de déchet ici on vend
quelques alternatives durables
donc vous avez effectivement des savons
pour le corps mais aussi des shampoings
tous ces produits vous pouvez
effectivement les acheter mais vous
pouvez aussi les fabriquer vous même ici
à la maison de leurs déchets on vous
accompagne avec des ateliers pour
fabriquer votre propre des eaux ou votre
propre shampoing aussi fabriquer vos
propres produits d'entretien mais aussi
des ateliers couture ou des ateliers
pour apprendre à réparer votre petit
électroménager bonjour je m'appelle
marina je me suis engagé dans une
démarche zéro déchet depuis environ un
an
je vous emmener faire les courses avec
moi parce que c'est notamment en
modifiant ma façon de faire les courses
que j'ai réussi à réduire les déchets de
50%
suivez-moi
[Musique]
du coup je viens avec mes contenant
faire les courses j'ai fait peser mais
contenant à la caisse juste avant donc
j'ai une étiquette qui indique que l'un
contenant fait 222 g
je remplis ma boîte avec le sucre qui
est en vrac pour ce qui me concerne nous
au sein de notre famille on a réduit sur
les sur la poubelle jaune donc tout ce
qui est recyclable de 70%
notamment parce qu'on va faire nos
courses en vrac où je m'étais dit si on
va dans un magasin bio avec du vrac et
hydra ça va être plus cher en réalité
non pour des produits comparable avec ce
que j'avais l'habitude d'acheter dans un
magasin d'un supermarché assez répandu
en france le prix leva plus élevé quand
on regarde sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
des gens qui font du zéro déchet mais un
point très poussées et moi je fais ce
que je peux avec mes moyens humains
temporel parce que je travaille mon mari
travaille on a des enfants
pour autant c'est possible ça c'est
plutôt le type de produit ou d'aliments
qu'on pouvait avoir l'habitude
d'utiliser avant d'être rentré dans la
démarche zéro déchet tout ça on n'a plus
trop l'habitude d'en avoir la maison du
coup ce qu'on fait c'est que comme jeu
comme on fait nos courses en vrac je
réutilise des contenants que j'avais
déjà serré utiliser des boîtes d'une
marque de boisson chocolatée faut mettre
toutes mes tous nos produits donc ça
c'est les pattes en vrac et ça c'est les
pattes acheter qui sont emballés
maintenant j'achète mon huile d'olive ou
mon huile de tournesol le vinaigre la
sauce soja
en vrac il suffit d'y aller avec la
bouteille et ont rempli le contenant
donc exit les bouteilles en plastique ça
quand je rentre des courses tout ça faut
que je le met à la poubelle
là j'ai rien à jeter à la poubelle je
rentre des courses et jeux mais
directement dans mon placard donc je
gagne aussi du temps là dessus
davantage quand même c'est de réfléchir
à ses propres comportements et surtout
de rayonner autour de soi est de montrer
que c'est possible c'est peut-être ça le
message si vous avez des amis qui ont
envie de s'y mettre ici mettront
peut-être qu'ils s'y mettront pas mais
il faut autre chose pour réduire les
déchets peut-être qu'ils pourront
influencer de manière plus importante
les décisions politiques mais je pense
que ça peut faire un effet boule de
neige
[Musique]